je pensais que j'allais trouver une
galanterie une une certaine politesse
mais ça je n'ai pas trouvé moi mon
impression est que les Français sont
très très méfiants des étrangers ils
sont tous divorcés et ils sont tous
séparés ils sont évidemment coureurs
l'homme est supérieur j'ai l'impression
et les femme elle est comme ça un peu
elle regarde son mari ce qui me frappe
le plus c'est les femmes montant dans le
métro avec deux ou trois gosses qui
prendent une siège pour chaque gosse
quand les vieilles dames sont debout
sont pas les parents qui élèvent
l'enfant mais son lestit l'école frappe
trop toujours toujours dans le par comme
ça cela me semble incroyable que le
français tienne extraordinairement sa
petite voiture j'ai remarqué qu'il
trempe tout dans son café ça j'ai jamais
vu avant le croiss le pain c'est
dégoûtant